the turkish lira tumbled more than one
percent against the u.s dollar after
president recep tayyip erdogan called
for the expulsion of ambassadors from 10
countries including germany and the
united states who had appealed for the
release of a jailed civil society leader
financial market experts are saying that
erdogan is trying to distract from
turkey's desolate economic situation
inflation there has reached almost 20
percent and the central bank has just
cut its lending rate by a full two
points possibly making matters worse yes
what people on the streets of istanbul
have to say about the situation
it's gotten so bad we can hardly survive
now
because i don't know if i can still make
a living tomorrow the situation is very
bad and we don't know if it's going to
get better or not
it's very bad
i got my salary and look i spent 250
lira just for this
she created an engineer people should be
thankful for this situation
do they know where we were 20 30 or 50
years ago
look how far we've come
but if some
but the coat gets even more expensive
than last month why because the dollar
has increased against the lira it's not
the same as the last month
well those were the voices
we caught on the streets of istanbul and
for more on the situation in turkey i'm
joined now by aydah yalzin professor of
international economics at the
university of applied sciences in
konstanz good to have you with us uh
before we start about uh the economy
let's start with the political rift
between ankara and its western
allies there are people who say that
erdogan simply wants to deflect from
turkey's economic woes do you agree
well indeed what we see in the last days
but also month is a turkish government
that is politically isolated
increasingly confronted with an alien
economy and also a dissatisfaction in
the turkish society and it looks like
that the government has no roadmap at
hand how to handle situations so the
strategy is uh seems to be to basically
create a narrative that there are
foreign forces trying to harm
turkey and with this narrative the
government tries to gather the remaining
supporters but this is not going to help
certainly not to to reach a turning
point for the ailing economy
so you say the government does not have
a road map what about the turkish
central bank it's just reduced its
policy rate uh the state banks are
following suit uh both a rather unusual
step in this current situation what's
the rationale behind this move
well first of all let me mention uh well
the turkish central bank announces 200
basis points drop in its policy rate but
there is a broad consensus that the
president himself of the turkish
republic gave an order to reduce the
interest rate so there is no independent
central bank in turkey anymore and the
logic of the government seems to be
there is a hope that with this low
interest rate the lira will weaken and
therefore turkish exports will in the
coming months increase be supported and
simultaneously lower interest rates in
turkey will make credits cheaper and
this should support domestic demand
enhanced growth however you know from
this is a very simplified assessment of
the economic relationship
the major problem of turkey is its high
inflation
and unfortunately the policy decision of
the central bank or the president's
decision is going to spur inflation
further on this is going to harm the
turkish economy more just to give you
some examples what will happen is people
are going to change their savings into
dollar dollarization is going to
increase capital foreign investors are
going to leave the country this is going
to harm investment and this is going to
to increase the problems of the turkish
economy
uh just briefly you mentioned already
capital flight obviously is a problem
where does this leave the economy which
is already a ailing
well the direct effect will be a
continuous weakening of the turkish lira
and the problem of a weakening lyrics of
course turkish goods become cheaper but
turkey is importing a lot of goods in
particular on the energy sector and also
in the agriculture sector meaning that
the inflation is going to increase and
this again
is going to to
result in a higher capital flight no
investment is going to take in turkey
anymore or investment is declining as a
result output is shrinking and this
basically means prices will increase
inflation is again increasing so it's a
vicious circle it's only accelerating
the problems therefore from an economic
point of view it's an irrational step
it's a political decision it's not an
economic decision
professor yeltsin as always thank you so
much for sharing your insights with us
i thank you very much
and of course financial markets are also
following the events in turkey
congratulations bye for us at the
frankfurt stock exchange conrad against
the the euro the lira even lost
6
that is a new record low
what's the word on the floor
well of course this is causing lots of
nervousness lots of disruption on the
financial markets
you know ratings agencies are of course
on high alert as are many investors who
have put money into turkey for them the
question is
who wants to hold a loan who wants to
hold an asset in a currency that's as
unpredictable as the turkish lira and
for the many many german companies who
are operative in turkey with thousands
of employees there
the question of course in the long run
is
what shall we do with our engagement in
turkey shall we keep it or shall we
rather get out of the country all right
difficult situation conrad bush in
frankfurt thank you